[Music]
why does everyone ask how I'm feeling I
got done a huge deal
I got the election I got a 10.
plenty on my plate he's on the floor tom
explain me what he's doing he's losing
terrifyingly nosy it's like if Santa
Claus was a hit man
we were cut out behind our backs
but there's a shape for things for us
we partner up with Sandy and Stewie with
Pierce
death wrestling ogres
excited to get into this knife fight
let's blow it up yeah I'm not authorized
to let you take off it's Dad you know in
Buddhism sometimes your greatest
Tormentor can also be your most
perceptive teacher hey Buddha nice Tom
Ford
there's a night of the Long Knives
coming I need a fire breather to help
with maths you really want me I need you
Mr Menken my most unworthy opponent
still clinging to your slice of pie
what are you at now one person the fear
is it could get squeezed
squeeze down from one because that's the
lowest number
I love you
but you are not serious people
I have it on good authority there is a
kill list
is your head on straight
we've been schooled by a barbarian that
goes by the name Logan Roy I mean he's
out of control
you want to clear the air you're a snake
you have hurt me more than you can
possibly imagine I have some concerns
about your old man I will sue and I will
go public you point your finger at me I
point my finger at you we are gonna
grind you down man we are sanding the
gears I hate you do you understand that
loud and clear good done
I'm gonna build something bigger faster
Wilder
Ness
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign